well there is no doubt that the
heartland mansion has been a staple in
las vegas history eight news now first
told you about the property's grim
future but now a newlywed is speaking
out heartbroken about how their venue
plans were changed last minute
i was in such shock i was very upset it
was supposed to be one of the most
important days of her life now megan
keaney describes her dream wedding she
envisioned inside las vegas's heartland
mansion we had a little terrace we're
going to have a little band play while
we get married and
on the grassy area the pool is covered
that was the dance floor
that was supposed to be like fun keaney
says she booked her wedding through
mansion 54 but three weeks before her
june 27th wedding date the couple was
notified that the venue had been
purchased by a new owner and all events
were cancelled we reached out to mansion
54 but their listed phone is no longer
working it's not ideal we have you know
we already had our you know save the
dates with the mansion on there our you
know our rsvp's our website said you
know the mansion stay at the nugget
county records show the home on six and
park paseo was sold in may of this year
for four million dollars to lanny dean
love owner of the adult super
city officials telling 8 news now the
popular venue where celebrities visited
and filled with eye-catching decor is on
track to be demolished at the owner's
request today workers were at the site
carrying items into this white van they
claim love requested before the property
is torn down in the end megan and her
husband gary's wedding did happen just
not at their choice venue because the
mansion spoke to us so much our colors
were black white and gold
and our officiant was elvis anyway so we
thought oh let's do it at the mansion
it'll be great with all the history and
everything there this is what i wanted
to go and it does not